all right so we have to remember H5 okay
um oh I got it high five oh I see oh
that's good that's what you're trying to
do they're trying to figure out a
mnemonic device uh okay high fives came
out in the 70s that's when they were
invented that's a seven yeah there's two
of us so so if you subtract two from
Seven that's five okay great so you got
it so and then um there's five minutes
just food groups why are you going on oh
no you're gonna love this it's just this
is fun for me because it's a puzzle nope
no puzzle okay five major food groups
there's meat vegetables grain Dairy and
fruits okay my favorite fruit is
pineapple but you know that we got it
already pineapple comes from Hawaii okay
my favorite current show is Hawaii
Five-O Hawaii Five-0 okay so that's it
done we're done Scott Scott Khan is the
star of Hawaii Five-O we're really
talking about his father is James Khan
who's one of the five major stars of the
one of the five major huge Stars each
right of